salut ça vas bien ouais je su content de
te rencontrerussi fait
plaisirtaisé coolé
bien oua le premier on était un peu on a
du mal à rentrer dedans quoi oui oui
c'était prévisible ça aurit pu être
pire là c'est l après on va Marseille on
finit à Lille
l'Italie c'est ouais on en novembre
contre il fait un bruit le
stade beaucoup plus grand mais
finalcoute je t'en
prie c'est moi qui
[Musique]
t
voilà c'est tellement chouette de vous
voir tous les deux assis sur ce cané
c'est la première fois que vous
rencontre et oui ouais ouis ouais alors
lequel est le plus impressionné par
l' je pense que c'est moi on va pas
poser la question mais non mais c'est
beau de le voir ici après le match en
plus comme ça après le match d'ouverture
magnifique non je m'y attendais pasand
on commencer à m'en parler je savais que
ça allait me faire bizarre on est
tellement habitué à le voir à la télé
partout depuis depuis tout petit donc ça
fait bizarre de le voir en vra il est
réel finalement il le
toucher tu fais partie de tes tes idoles
gens B oui évidemment je pense que
99 % je peut-être des français quand
j'étais petit j'ai j'ai crié devant ses
exploits à la télé même si le début de
sa carrière j'étais quand même un peu
petit mais sur la fin surtout la Coupe
du monde 2006 cétait incroyable c'est
des moments donc je me souviens
évidemment encore aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui c'est zedine qui crie devant
devant tes exploit qui crie Antoine
exactement l'équipe de France non
c'était bien c'est moi je suis je suis
content parce que c'est c'est pareil
enfin on suit le rugby on adore ça on
adore l'équipe de France et puis voilà
les voir gagner comme ça en France ça ça
nous ça me rappelle ça me rappelle plein
de choses donc voilà longtemps après
mais perdu les cheveux depuis on a bougé
un peu mais bon ça me rappelle plein de
choses donc c'est je je je je m'imagine
ce qu'il est en train de ce qu'il est en
train de vivre donc voilà c'est ça qui
est top ce que j'ai envie de dire
Antoine c'est justement de profiter
profiter de l'événement du moment de ce
qu'il est en train de vivre là quoi
aujourd'hui quoi c'est ça mais c'est
pour ça que moi j' j'avais un petit peu
peur parce que c'est toujours pareil la
compétition comme il a dit enfin un peu
quand tu commences une compétition tu es
chez toi tu es en France ton public la
première mi-temps justement c'était
c'était c'était compliqué et après ils
se sont libérés en deè-temps mais
d'avoir gagné c'est
vraiment là tout le monde va les porter
quoi en c'est ça c'est ce qu'il fallait
quoi c'estàd le premier match c'est
toujours important de pousser tout le
monde vers toi ENF avec toi point de vue
symbolique de gagner le match
d'ouverture contre les All Black à
domicile ça lance toute la Coupe du
monde ça emporte tous les gens avec nous
on sait aussi que les gens qui sont pas
forcément passionnés de rugby ils vont
se ils vont arriver pour soit les phases
finales ou les gros matchs et là c'est
un gros match qui va faire parler et qui
va je l'espère rassembler le le plus de
monde derrière nous quoi vous avez dit
qu'il faut en profiter une coupe du
monde à la maison est-ce qu'on arrive à
en profiter ouais ah oui oui ah puis tu
B tu bas les Black d'entrée c'est
magnifique après on va voir c'est c'est
que le début mais c'est mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est beau de commencer comme ça
ouais de sentir l'engouement populaire
on a vu les images à la Concorde nous au
capital de voir le nombre de gens qui
qu'on qu'on rassemble on sent bien que
c'est un événement qui est différent de
tout ce qu'on a connu jusqu'à maintenant
donc c'est sûr quand on est dans le truc
on a un peu du mal à prendre ce recul là
à profiter savourer de le moment mais il
faut qu' il faut qu'on y arrive parce
qu'en plus la compète elle est elle est
quand même très longue la finale c'est
le 28 octobre donc déjà j'espère qu'
qu'on y arrivera mais déjà d'ici là il y
aura beaucoup de choses qui vont se
passer et si on arrive pas à profiter un
peu des moments de joie ça peut être
pesant psychologiquement aussi je pense
moi je me rappelle du du notre match
c'est c'était aussi compliqué surtout la
veille de de notre match fait
unentraînement c'est catastrophique et
c'était c'était bizarre quoi de faire un
entraînement comme ça av un coup du mond
c'est du pur min et finalement le match
s'est bien passé et puis après on a été
porté par par tout le monde pareil on
les a on les a amené un peu avec nous et
justement ils ont répondu présent donc
c'est ce qui se passein voilà moi j'ai
confiance en Toine son équipe avec ce
qu'ils ont fait ils VT monter en
puissance et tout donc voilà c'est
j'avais un petit peu peur justement pour
le pour le premier match mais voilà ça s
bien passé c'est peut-être la première
fois que les gens espèrent autant que
qu'on la gagne déjà on la reçoit
évidemment mais aussi on arrive à être
dans les premiers mondiaux comme je
disais depuis 4 ans maintenant ce qui
était quasiment jamais arrivé donc ça
met une pression supplémentaire mais
aussi beaucoup d'espoir et de de
confiance de mais de savoir qu'on est
capable de de gagner des matchs
importants de gagner des matchs sous
pression de gagner des compétitions on a
gagné le signation en 2022 et donc oui
il y a toujours un petit truc en plus
mais il faut arriver à avir le le côté
positif prendre les énergies positives
le public tout ce qui peut nous amener
pour que ça nous nous serve plus que
nous desserve sur le terrain après
magnifique vous avvez également cette
pression ENF
oui forcément forcément un petit peu
mais on s'en est servi euh positivement
aussi c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai qu'il
y a cette pression de se dire bon voilà
on est en France on est on est chez nous
on a on a envie de de garder la Coupe du
monde mais bon on avait on était sûr de
nos forces aussi c'est dire que on
savait qu'on pouvait faire une belle
coupe du monde c'est ce qu'on a ce qu'on
a fait on est monté en puissance petite
à petit et on était poussé par tout le
monde donc ouais pression mais c'est
comment toi tu te la gères la pression
et
nous vraiment enfin les on avait les
meilleurs joueurs comme comme il se
passe aujourd'hui dans dans l'équipe
enfin je veux dire un équilibre
incroyable il le dit ton enfin depuis 4
ans et voilà que des beaux matchs que
des belles victoires que des belles
choses doncon
que ça
continue est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
de de zédine dont vous pourriez vous
inspirer sur le terrain ah ben oui je
pense même si c'est pas le le même sport
je pense que même au-delà deprès de 98
le le statut qui qu'il a eu et qu'il a
assumé d'être présent dans les dans dans
les gros match dans les grands
rendez-vous je parlais moi de de 2006
mais je me souviens toutes les les
phases finales le match contre le Brésil
on a vu que lui donc c'est les gros
matchs importants d'être présent dans
ces matchs décisifs ben c'est ça qui est
le plus important pour les les joueurs
clés quand on est parler des décisions
stratégiques et que malgré l'enjeu
d'arriver à jouer son jeu être à son
meilleur niveau c'est et a regarder
cette créativité aussi Qui est qui est
hyper importante moi particulièrement ce
que ce qui ce qui se dégage en fait dans
tous les cas d'antoin c'est ça c'est sa
c'est sa tranquillité c'est-à-dire que
il fait vraiment les
choses
avec beaucoup d'assurance et ça se sent
enfin ve dire moi c'est coéquipi voilà
il se rassure un petit peu tout le monde
quand il quand il as le ballon quand bon
on pas parler de de ses passes de ses
trucs parce que voilà c'est magnifique
bon mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
moi c'est ce côté à son âge qui est un
jeune âge il met beaucoup de de sérénité
dans ça dans une équipe on a toujours
besoin de d'un leader de de terrain ce
qu'il est mais aussi de voilà les gars
ça va aller vous inquiétez pas quand on
les prend individuellement ils ont tous
quelque chose de particulier et lui
voilà c'est le meneur c'est celui qui
qui donne un peu le tempo moi jeantine
c'est la première fois que je je le vois
et c'est ce qui est aussi ce que ce qui
est me vois un petit peu en lui c'est
c'est aussi ce côté en dehors du terrain
tranquille je
suis un peu timide un peu réservé un peu
machin à ma place mais c'est ça qui est
bien et sur le terrain je je donne ce
qu'il faut quoi
fa
bizar le voir aujourd'hui je savais pas
qu' qui savait que j'existais donc ça
fait bizar qui parle de moi mais
évidemment ça m'a fait super plaisir
j'écoute toutes ces paroles j'aurais d
prendre un carnet pour prendre des
notes cont de faire rentrer Fran dans
nouelle ah oui oui ou bah la question
elle est simple et la réponse elle est
simple ce que je veux dire c'est que là
par exemple championnat du monde de
maison voilà ça serait bien de ça serait
bien de garder la Coupe du monde d'avoir
la Coupe du monde pendant un temps ici
mais et qui par contre après sa vie le
problème c'est ça c'est qu'elle va
changer mais bon ça ça vaut ça vaut le
coup moi j'y crois en tous les cas on va
on va continuer à suivre Antoine avecou
on va regarder et puis hier on était là
et puis on va regarder ça
c'est et bonne chance mais merci qu'un
supporter de choix comme ça on risque
rien